- [Evan] If you just work for
money, you'll never make it.
But if you love what you're
doing, success will be yours.
Ray Kroc.
I want to make a million dollars
before I turn X years old.
Sound familiar?
Most new entrepreneurs are
just trying to make money
and that's why they fail.
They're tired of working for someone else
and think you can strike
it rich by branching off
on your own.
You're partly right.
If you look at any list of
the world's wealthiest people
and remove those who had inherited wealth,
almost everyone else is an entrepreneur.
You don't make real money
working for someone else.
But and this is a huge but,
if money is your only goal
then you'll never be rich.
Look at the list at the most
successful entrepreneurs
and you'll see that none of
them are driven by the money.
They want to change the
way something is done.
They want to have an impact.
They want to leave a legacy.
To be successful as an entrepreneur,
you need to build a
business around your passion
and use your one word as
your operating philosophy.
You're not running a charity
here, unless you are.
Money is important.
You're here to create profits and wealth
but it's not the most important thing.
Success leaves clues.
Still don't believe that
money should never be your
primary goal?
Here are some more examples to follow.
I encourage you to look up
your favorite entrepreneur
and see how they got started
and what their priorities were.
Richard Branson said, never
go into business purely
to make money, if that's the
sole motive you're better off
doing nothing.
Chris Gardner said, you
have to be committed
and you have to find something
that you are passionate
about and forget about money.
Joyce Clyde Hall said, if
a man goes into business
with only the idea of
making a lot of money,
chances are he won't.
But if he puts service and quality first,
the money will take care of itself.
Producing a first class
product that is a real need
is a much stronger motivation for success
than getting rich.
Oprah Winfrey said, what I
know is, is that if you do work
that you love and work that fulfills you,
the rest will come and I
truly believe that the reason
I've been able to be so
financially successful
is because my focus has
never ever for one minute
been money.
Walt Disney said, Disneyland
is a work of love.
We didn't go into Disneyland
just with the idea
of making money.
Donald Trump said, the most
important thing in life
is to love what you're doing
because that's the only way
you'll ever be good at.
Money was never a motivation
for me except as a way
to keep score.
The real excitement is
in playing the game.
And Jennifer Lopez said,
if you focus on the money,
you're not going to get anywhere.
You can want to be successful
but at the end of the day,
if money is your motivation,
if that's how shallow your
outlook is on life, then
you're going to be such
an empty person because
there's nothing driving
you from the inside, there's no passion.